so one of the most common requests that
I've received from you guys for videos
to make is to make a video about the
presence to make a video about DC's
version of God the prime mover the
origin of all things whatever whatever
name you choose to ascribe to it the
problem with this is that the presence
is such a difficult character to do
because there really isn't anything on
his character there really aren't a
whole lot of things that we can look at
but I found a couple of examples that
will give us a good idea of what the
presence is and so what we're going to
do here is we're going to kind of make
this compare and contrast to the
presence and the God of Abraham and the
reason why is because unlike Marvel
Comics where we have characters like the
one above all or we have characters at
The Living Tribunal while those
characters are not based on any kind of
religious figures that is to say we
can't look at the Living Tribunal and
say this character equates to Jesus or
this character equates to God but the
presence we can because the presence was
explicitly designed to basically be the
God of Abraham to be the god of
judeo-christianity with the presence he
comes in a couple forms two of the most
notable forms are a voice as well as a
hand and it's really kind of weird here
with the Justice League of America issue
number 124 and 1975 I think this is
probably one of the best depictions of
the presence in terms of it being a
booming voice in the sky basically as we
know the spectre is the result of the
presence establishing or I guess giving
a man hitherto almost unrivaled
abilities in the realm of DC Comics but
there comes a point whereby the spectre
attempts to speak with the presence
whereby it appeals directly to the
presence asking the presence to
resurrect the Justice Society of America
now this particular instance this
particular coming book page basically
tells us that the way in which the
spectre tries to relate to the presence
is almost addictive of the way that the
that Moses tried to speak with God
through vert by virtue of the burning
bush net rather than actually speaking
directly with the presence that is to
say speaking face-to-face the presence
taking on some kind of a form and
talking to the specter instead it's
literally just a booming voice whereby
the present says that basically it
understands the appeal of the spectre
it recognizes the value of what is
inspectors asking and that it will
consider the request of the specter but
this again basically gives us the idea
that those who communicate with the
presence do so in the exact same way
that you would see somebody in the real
world trying to communicate with God
whereby they're basically praying that's
pretty much what we're getting here is
the specter as it's praying to the
presence now the next instance comes in
the Green Lantern vol 2 issue number 40
now with the Green Lantern vol 2 issue
number 40 again as we know with the
history of the Green Lantern Corps the
Green Lantern Corps came into existence
at the hands of the guardians of the
universe and the guardians of the
universe did this because a member of
their race named Crona had basically
gone through gone back to the origin of
time and by virtue created the
anti-monitor unintentionally and the
result was the crisis on Infinite Earths
event and so what happens here is that s
Crona is going through and looking at
these various points throughout the
history of creation in the DC Universe
we see an instance where by it seems a
some kind of phantom hand reaches out
from a plane of existence that we don't
know and seems to basically create
everything and in fact Cronus seems to
say this appears to be the origin of
creation this appears to be the point
whereby everything was made but there's
still a place or Stila
I guess further back that he can go
which of course he does and again as we
know it results in the formation of the
anti-monitor but this again is the idea
that the presence as it exists exists as
this kind of disembodied spirit that no
one knows what the presence actually
looks like what the actual form of the
presence is no one knows if the presence
really even has a form or if the
presence simply just takes on whatever
form any particular race would
understand when they view it and then
tries to communicate with them in that
fashion now again
there are elements of the presence that
spill into vertical comics but because
of the fact that we're focusing mainly
on DC the main DC Comics this seems to
be really all the information we have
again the presence is a character that
was designed to be very enoch matic it
was designed to be a character to
basically just step in and to say this
individual or this being is responsible
for the creation of everything and
really just kind of leave it at that it
was basically DC's way to answer the
question a word of everything in the DC
Universe come from
how did all this get started in DC get
someone just point to the presence and
say the presence did it and then just
leave it there so with that being said
um I know this was a long video but
again there really isn't much to go on
when it comes to the presence it's just
a very small amount of information so
with that being said I will catch you
guys later
you